so I'm going to be talking today about
some aspects of the changing
autism and some of the challenges and
opportunities that have to do with
working with adolescents and adults as
always I want to be politically correct
and cite the various grants some support
much of our work here and also to point
out a couple of publications which is a
handy way of also advertising one's
books I want to talk today about some
challenges in terms of thinking about
our understanding of autism he'll
outcome seems to be changing over time
and maybe a little bit about the
economics of autism and also how do we
understand what's happened in terms of
some of the changes and finally thinking
about what can we do in terms of having
a better job of translating research
into practice I want to thank a number
of the associates especially Debian
Larry hillebrand I'll come back to them
at the very end of the talk they've
actually funded a new fellowship program
for a person interested in work with
adolescents and adults with autism and
related disabilities I don't know if
Rogers in the audience Roger Joe is our
first fellow actually the hillebrand
fellows and that will be ongoing will be
starting a search for a person for next
year as well also various foundations
and granting agencies publishers and
we'll talk about YouTube at the very end
so let me start with some caveats as
Mark Twain once said I've seen a hop
heap of trouble of my life most of it
never came to pass so I do I don't to be
too negative but i also want to flag in
the course of this talk some things are
a little bit worrisome on the horizon
and as always predicting the past is
much easier than predicting the future
and the question of what we should try
to go in terms of new directions and
disabilities research is important and
finally let me just remind you of that
famous quote from Israeli that there are
three kinds of lies lies damned lies and
statistics and I'm going to show you a
little bit of statistics not too much
but take everything with a certain grain
of salt so some paradoxes and challenges
autism was once thought to be rare now
it's thought to be very common dr.
mcpartlin and I were just seeing a
family debating the question of the
mother was confused about is it autism
is an autism spectrum does it make any
difference and it's an interesting
question as we sort of had I don't say
diagnosis creep
people start to think more broadly about
autism and related conditions it seems
much more common on the other hand
hardcore classical autism which will say
a little bit about remains the sir major
prototype of the disorders in this group
and the one where most of the research I
mean almost all of the research is done
people probably know that there was
early confusion of autism was it a kind
of schizophrenia for many years that was
the only term that was available to
describe children with autism childhood
schizophrenia schizophrenic reaction of
childhood that only changed in 1980 so
in that sense autism is official
diagnosis has only been around for a
short period of time it's interesting
we're going to talk a lot about the
research to the extent that I can about
research with adolescents and adults
keep in mind that probably 90 plus
percent of the research these days is on
toddlers and infants and so there are
these funny disparities in terms of who
is who has studied and who needs
services there's also some interesting
diagnostic tensions which will probably
have a chance to come back to and
certainly if people ask me questions we
could talk a little about it there's the
tension we're currently of lumping and
splitting autism autism spectrum five
disorders one disorder I'll say a little
bit about that Oh a comorbidity I'll say
a little bit about comorbidity that's
the idea of having more than one thing
autism plus depression anxiety troubles
a DD it's a very interesting and
complicated area very quickly to recap
the checkered history of autism Connor
in 1943 giveth a the first definition he
said these were children had autism they
were alone in the world you talked about
autistic aloneness in a very wonderful
way he also said they had trouble with
dealing with the non social aspects of
the environment what he ended up calling
resistance to change her insistence on
sameness covers it interestingly a
multitude of sins but it's an
interesting thing when you think about
it because he was contrasting the lack
of social interest in a certain way the
over engagement with the non social
world that kind of troubles with chain
means the kids really paying attention
there but not so much the parents and
other people michael rutter is the next
big person in the field in 1978 came out
with the first of the sort of something
approaching an operational definition of
autism he said you had to have
significant social problems worse than
you might expect given the person's
overall cognitive ability significant
problems of communication language and
these funny behaviors that sort of
so-called resistance to change
insistence on same as stereotyped
behaviors category and you had to have
it before age 3d sm-3 and 1980 was the
first to officially recognize autism the
definition in dsm three was very much
the michael rutter definition it was
also the infantile autism definition and
by that I mean it was most applicable to
very young children those four most
classical hardcore autism dsm three are
beard of the other direction and
actually opened up to some extent the
floodgates in terms of the autism
spectrum business especially at
overdiagnosed autism apparently among
the more severely cognitively challenged
the current system dsm for the
international system icd-10 are the same
this was done in the basis of a large
international field trial it was
actually centered here there's autism
and four other categories Asperger's ret
CDD in this funny pdd-nos category we
are looking at changes for dsm-5 we
actually just had to talk about this
last friday in the autism group the
fundamental problem dsm-5 it's a little
bit I shall have to be careful because
its ability of the web and some its some
previous administrations and it would
comment on the Obama administration when
people said something they meant the
opposite so paradoxically when you hear
in dsm-5 a new definition of autism
spectrum disorder as far as one can tell
that means classical autism there's not
much spectrum about it and in fact one
of the worries when they have a chance
to talk about this among the more
cognitively able people many of them
will lose their diagnosis and possibly
the eligibility for service and that's
actually a significant worry speaking
though just briefly of research in
autism I want to make a couple of points
this is lee o'connor first paper in
autism 1943 this is from medline i
emphasize you get different different
results depending on what's what's your
search and also of course depending on
what the keywords are this is looking
for either autistic disorder or ought to
them as keywords but here you can see in
five year blocks the number of papers
and it starts going up and up and up
here's DSM three kicking in and we're
starting to see a very significant
increase and here's the most recent
numbers this is done by year so this is
2000 2001 2010 the last year I have data
on and you can see that in 2010 there
were well over 1800 peer-reviewed papers
not chapters nut books peer-reviewed
papers on autism so you can imagine this
means you can have to where you how many
six papers a day to keep up which is
almost impossible now the good news is
there's so much more in terms of
research I'm not necessarily say it's
all of high quality but it's actually
surprisingly surprisingly good one of my
other jobs as editor the Journal of
autism is to manage a lot of this as it
comes through and every year we're up
five to ten percent in terms of the
submissions and every year our
acceptance rate keeps going down it's
now less than a third it's a happy
problem to have let me point out that
again with dsm-4 back here you can see
there's a steady increase so the system
has worked so far pretty well now why is
research increased well intellectually
autism turns out to be a fascinating
condition we know more about the social
brain i'm going to allude to some of
that we also know for the first time we
have the potential in a very truly
meaningful way bringing the brain and
jeans and behavior together for the
first time and it's really tremendously
exciting there also are social and
political reasons so we have support
from parent groups and we have
foundations when i first got into the
business people didn't know what the
word autism was now you can't go in the
radio and not hear about autism from
autism speaks or from the ad council
which is again it's a major major shift
we also have parents who have become
much more vociferous there's plenty of
room over here for people people parents
have been willing to talk to the first
time about the experience of having a
child they're willing to support other
parents which is fantastic unfortunately
one of the problems in the 70s was the
parents were often stigmatized as a
result of the work of Bettelheim and
some other people parents were often
blamed for causing their child's trouble
so it wasn't something people
wanted to talk about that's also changed
for the better also there are financial
reasons and I suspect those people the
room will know Willie Sutton people know
well he sat in a famous bank robber they
once asked Willie why he robbed banks
and he said because that's where the
money is and in this day and age where
NIH resources are decreasing happy news
for the autism folks this is still where
the money is as Tom Insel says it's
autism all the time and at NIH and it's
true there's a lot of interest at the
federal level I'll show you a slide on
that a second more immediate attention
and also a lot of stuff on the internet
anybody take a guess I can't tell you
today but I can tell you a month ago if
you type autism into Google how many
hits do you get 17 million now what
you're supposed to do with that I don't
know and we'll come back to tuk that's
it's actually it's a problem because the
good news about the Internet is it's
free and openly available it's very
convenient the bad news is it's not
policed here is a slide this is from the
Congress actually it's the Congress's
numbers that's why it stops in these odd
times but this is from the General
Accounting Office and it shows federal
activities in autism from 2000 2005 and
you can see they're getting up to 100
million dollars and it's even more now
this has again been very good news in
terms of stimulating research and work
in the area at the same time it's
interesting there are some challenges
the grant review process people will
know especially if they've either been
the recipient of a grant review or even
more interestingly been on a grant
review committee the system is not
perfect you basically have to have pilot
data to show that you could do the work
to get the money to do the work if you
can follow that so you have to have kind
of done the study before you can get the
money to do the study there also is a
big impact of fads and sort of the local
interest of the moment and that is an
important problem there are some real
challenges for treatment research
treatment research is some of the most
difficult to get funded I sometimes say
treatment research is a little like an
oriental carpet a good oriental carpet
there will always be something wrong
with it because you don't want to offend
God and the same thing with treatment
research there's always you can find
something wrong
and all it takes is one person to put
the knock the federal level at a grant
review on a grant and it's dead so
that's a problem so the treatment
intervention research is i'm going to
show you in just a second has stayed
relatively flat in the face of this
otherwise amazing increase in research
also hard to get access to relevant
groups some of the kinds of research we
might like to do were somewhat limited
given the nature of autism the
associations with developmental
disabilities of the issues of informed
consent that whole package of things and
finally i think in this country there's
been a lack of emphasis on translational
research when you review grants for the
Wellcome Trust or the Brits there's a
little section in the grant that asks
the researchers say tell us how are you
going to translate this into something
is going to be useful to parents and
schools into the lay public and I think
that's actually a nice feature that we
have not perhaps emphasized as much this
is especially true when we talk about
older children adolescents and adults
and this slide just shows you the
relative lack of growth in treatment
studies so this is the gray bars of the
upsurge in autism research reports but
these are the ones that are treatment so
you can see it has not kept pace in
general there's more than there used to
be but still not nearly as much and much
of this is it plated by single case
studies economic issues autism is a
costly problem gans up in boston has
educated has estimated that back in two
thousand six in the u.s. it was
typically at that point costing about
3.2 million dollars for a person over
the course of their lifetime he thought
we were spending about 35 billion
dollars annually in this country in
autism martin nap in the UK another
economists economist estimated that they
were spending about 25 billion pounds a
year so this is a costly problem
increasing functional outcome has
important economic as well as social
policy and ethical implications so the
happy news is if we can convince the
policymakers this is something to put
money in there's a good payoff literally
so let me into some funny way start with
the end of the talk that we'll we'll
recap outcome in autism there's an
excellent review by Pat Helen in 2005
and the handbook of autism she points
out that there are many differences in
terms of people doing out
studies there's differences in maps
that's difference in terms of criteria
used in general however the trend has
been towards better adult outcome more
individuals with autism are talking more
have higher levels of cognitive ability
more employed there still is the
recurrent problem what it means to be
quote unquote normal or cured of autism
over all the years I've seen oh gosh
somewhere between probably seven and ten
thousand patients I've maybe seen four
or five that I would say of meeting them
I didn't realize they had autism as
adults it's not impossible but it's
relatively rare more typically you see
people with social oddities other kinds
of issues and I'm not knocking that but
people sometimes will want to say oh
this kids cured where he's quote unquote
normal and well and there is a broad
range of normal but it's an interesting
dilemma but there's no question that
outcome in general is getting better so
there are some issues in terms of
thinking about looking at the outcome
research that early confusion about
autism and schizophrenia was a problem
there have been some changes in criteria
back with dsm-4 there was an attempt to
make the criteria more neutral to IQ so
that would pick up fewer of the lower
functioning and more of the more able
people that that was actually a very
explicit stated goal of the process that
we wanted to be IQ neutral as a system
and the stringency of definition
obviously has a lot of bearing
loosey-goosey is going to be one thing
hardcore classical autism another also
some very important changes in
intervention in this country public law
94-142 what now is called ideea for the
first time mandated schools to provide
services to children with handicaps this
was a watershed event in this country
similar things happened in other
countries like in England but this made
a major major difference up to that
point schools could and often did say to
parents of young children with autism we
can't educate this child put them away
somewhere and that happened people ended
up at state training schools Mansfield
police's like that where they learn to
live in institutions and as time went on
people realize that was not such a happy
thing and it was actually separating
kids from their families just preventing
optimal growth and outcome and with
public law 94-142 for the first time
schools were mandated to provide a free
and appropriate education
the other things had had to do with
important changes in early detection
people we were just talking this morning
we had three cases in the autism clinic
we always have one case under three in
this today I guess we had two cases
under three we've seen not infrequently
children under a year that's a major
change from even ten years ago and 20
years ago seeing a four-year-old was
young child with autism um in
methodological issues there's a lot of
different approaches people have taken
to quantitating outcome the happy news
is that Pat Hallam has done a good job
of summarizing this so she has three
categories and good fair and poor good
means moderate to high levels of
Independence self-sufficiency as adults
with some friends and acquaintances fair
means need some support at work or home
but somewhat degree of autonomy so some
degree of personal independence and
self-sufficiency poor means living in
situations where there's essentially
24-7 observation so it's more
residential settings and again I
emphasize the storm will see business is
a bit of a red herring if anybody's
interested we can talk more about it so
i am going to cherry-pick studies i'm
going to tell you why in a second I am
cherry taking the first studies from 56
to 74 these are good summarized by Pat
Hallam here's good fair and poor outcome
and you can see that in these studies
the first ones actually by Lee O'Connor
and Leon Eisenberg and going up to 74
and i'll tell you why we stopped in 74
in a second but you can see that on
average the good outcome meaning adult
independent self-sufficient maybe
averaging five six percent most people
ending up two-thirds in institutional
settings as adults and now I'm cherry
picking from a different cohort 89 to
2003 now look what's happened with the
good we're averaging about twenty-five
percent and there's good reason to think
this number is continuing to change for
the better this is great now why am I
cherry picking these funny ears so I'm
cherry picking the first studies that
were done before public law 94-142
kicked it before service was banned
dated and then I'm cherry-picking after
public law 94-142 but before dsm-4 which
might have introduced artificial changes
and outcome but you're going to sense
that there's
seems to be something really truly going
on here now why is this well it seems to
be several things we do think that
earlier diagnosis intervention makes a
big difference it leads to much better
outcome as a group the problem for the
individual child as Jamie Andrea and
Michelle and I were talking this morning
with the family the individual child is
hard to predict that as groups we can do
a better job and as a group kids are
doing better with intervention there is
some contribution probably of the
broader diagnostic practice to this but
it's probably relatively small and we do
think there are more and better supports
and intervention tools there's
technology we could talk to the family
today about a technology tool I prompts
which you can download to your iPad or
your iPhone and it's a great little
handy thing for kids on the autism
spectrum now again issues not every
child gets better even kids that were
sometimes optimistic about in good
programs for reasons we don't always
understand don't always do well there
are always issues of matching children
to treatments it will be typically the
case the school has an autism program
they will have their program it may be
at each model program it might be a
Denver model program it might be an ABA
program the problem is what if you have
a child who might not do so well with
that particular kind of program it would
be better with another one so that's a
funny problem and there has been a
dearth of studies on older individuals
for anyone interested in treatment
there's a wonderful book called
educating children with autism from the
National Research Council it focuses on
young children came out about ten years
ago now it was really a landmark in the
field Cathy Lord was the chairperson of
a committee of I was on Sally Rogers
sandy Harris a bunch of folks and we
looked at all the data looking at
outcome and autism and early diagnosis
this has been prompt this was prompted
by a question in the united states
department of education does
intervention make a difference to which
the short answer is yes it makes a big
difference the kinds of intervention
programs i think we looked at 10
programs around the country structured
intensive intervention they have many
commonalities and a few differences
again we emphasized not every child gets
better but as a group there appeared to
be improving outcome looking at any
number of metrics and early and
sustained intervention was really
important
also we talked about the early efforts
with major tranquilizers has been some
work subsequently and we actually now
have some drugs that have been approved
specifically for the treatment of autism
so what's our understanding of the model
of autism what's the trouble we were
talking about this with the family
that's just this morning autism i'm
going to show you more in a second is a
disorder that profoundly impacts social
interaction and social information
processing if you have problems in
interpreting social information if the
social world is not so relevant to you
you're not such a good learner and
that's a sad reality so the trouble we
know as an autism has it has an
interfering aspect on development we can
actually quantitate now from some of the
studies we've shown in a second probably
about ninety percent of the social
effective information and ongoing
interaction is lost to the child with
classical autism it's like they have
blinders on so they're getting only a
small fraction of what's really going
through on the other hand the bit of
good news here development happens kids
with autism grow and change and they can
learn so the strategic as our former
president would say is this we want to
minimize the negative impact autism has
on learning and maximize as much as we
can the tendencies towards normal a
normative developmental processes and
that's it in a nutshell and that's it's
like the golden rule of autism
intervention if you can take that away
from this talk that's an important thing
to take away that really this is the
goal of treatment and this is what we
are trying to do now why don't we
understand about the social brain and
autism and we have a body work on this
Kevin I'm sure is going to be talking
about this later in the year this is a
study from some years ago that was done
here Bob Schultz was the first author
this was a study looking at more able
people looking at faces and the fusiform
gyrus this studies done been replicated
well over ten times and the bottom line
folks with autism and aspergers bright
people didn't seem to use the part of
the brain the fusiform face area that's
the rest of us use for looking at faces
they used it when they actually look at
their favorite objects but they didn't
use it for faces which is interesting so
in a census is if they see faces like
they see other objects they're not
special in the world and people probably
know that some of our work
early work on eye tracking which was
done with adults we found our surprise
very significant differences in the way
people with autism look at social scenes
so this is about 5-10 seconds of the
movie Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf and
this is done with a little tiny infrared
camera which is invisible we can
practice you exactly where the person's
looking the typical person turns out to
go back and forth between the eyes of
the speaker a very bright and successful
man with autism it turns out to our
surprise goes back and forth at the
mouth he tracks them out very
exclusively and this is an example when
I talk about the kind of information
that's lost so in this scene from the
movie this is just a couple of so frames
the young couple is talking with Liz and
Dick and George Segal young man stalking
his wife has had a couple of drinks too
many I'm sure this would never happen at
Yale this is some other new england
college and she starts to shore hirsch
ph and she's charged to embarrass her
husband so this is the interesting thing
the typical viewer starts with george
seagulls eyes sandy and his starts to
speak switches to her but then looks at
the husband who's not talking registers
affect the husband's embarrassed back to
her back to the husband back to her back
to the husband back and forth back and
forth sample sample sample person with
autism once she's up and running moves
from his mouth to her mouth never looks
at the husband would never know and this
turns out to be a surprisingly very
significant difference if you look at
where people are looking these are
getting very bright people with autism
this is looking at eyes and these few
clips of this very social moving that's
very intense social movie and you can
see there's no overlap of the
distribution that it's a very different
movie for the people with autism and
these are very bright people with autism
and if you quantitate this by turning it
into an effect size the effect size
there is three points something this is
a whopping effect size this is like a
z-score so this is an enormous effect
keep in mind in terms of our work sadly
with social skills interventions I think
the meta-analysis say the effect size is
something like point four so it's like
we're really pushing against the tide
with this but this is kind of what we're
trying to cope with and I know there's a
strong analytic presence at the child
study center so I want to throw this in
which is this wonderful scene in the
movie where liz taylor is making whoopee
with a young man in front of her husband
and this is the first concrete proof of
the Oedipus complex the typical viewer
is going Zoom Zoom Zoom but looking at
the husband who's not talking so looking
at Liz looking at George look at the
husband Liz you see that lovely oedipal
triangle the person with autism starts
at his mouth you think it looking at her
nether regions but in fact it's a little
misleading because their heads moving
but go back and forth to the mouth never
looks at the husband so what are the
challenges is we think about adolescents
and young adults well first of all
adolescents can be a challenge for
everybody there are lots of issues in
terms of medical care unfortunately one
of the problems and this becomes crew
even the more cognitively able parents
and kids try to avoid things that are
going to cause trouble doctors cause
trouble going to the doctor going to
dentist even worse and so these things
unfortunately tend to aggregate on top
of that we give medications which slowed
the person down often these are people
who are not really engaged in sports and
other kinds of physical activities
obesity is a problem one of the few
things that kid will do to be happy to
sit and eat the corn chips and for the
television and that causes its own sets
of issues in trouble we have behavior on
psychiatric interventions obviously but
these get somewhat more challenging as
kids get older as our colleagues and
adult psychiatry aren't quite
necessarily knowledgeable about what
what to do about them we have a lot of
supports that we can kick in in terms of
teaching adaptive skills we can teach
social skills and communication but
again you have to know what you're doing
to put those into place there's
challenges in terms of transition into
puberty for both boys and girls and then
into adulthood real significant problems
around insurance medical care
reimbursement issues and social and
vocational supports this often is an
area where of a little bit of help the
person can be helped in a major way in
terms of the difference it makes for
their life but the trouble is getting
that little bit of help some states like
ours it very much is focused on IQ
so in this state along with Alabama and
Mississippi if you don't have an IQ in
the mentally [ __ ] intellectually
disabled range forget it in terms of
services essentially there's some
experimentation now to try to work on
that that's a shame because this you
know though sore the next step of the
population are the people who could be
helped to become much much more
functional again adolescents puberty has
happens because of biology not because
of diagnosis often in Connor point of
this out behavior problems increase in
adolescents often about a year or so
before they start to see the signs in
terms of hair and body growth are there
issues of sexuality that can be very
rate limiting for adults there could be
many challenges relative to peers the
problems in social communication
so-called pragmatic language become more
and more and more problematic I give you
I can give you some examples so for
example we have a man who works for us
who's on the spectrum and it was copying
the first time I gave this person
something to copy there's a little
yellow paper on top and I said Joe which
is not his real name Joe could you make
three copies red and I come in the next
morning and he's written yes on the
paper are there three copies no because
he could yeah he could but actually the
fan that she laughs I want to point out
something that's interesting he didn't
intend it to be funny this is where his
life is lived so you can I mention a
high school student who's doing this all
the time and people are laughing at him
or her and they're not intending to be
funny but people are laughing anyway and
you can understand why sometimes when
I'm talking to mixed groups of parents
and teachers i can tell stories like
this I'll say I'm going to tell you a
story i can predict who's going to laugh
at who won't the parents won't because
they live with it they know it extends
into all kinds of other things
figurative language the phrase kiss my
butt you can imagine that can cause a
lot of trouble if you're very literal we
had one young man who like to comment on
ladies breasts this turns out it's one
thing when you're four year old it's
another thing when here a 15 year old
and fortunately he was able to transform
this with some effort and help and to
commenting on ladies breathing capacity
so it was still weird but it was much
less likely the police we're going to be
called if he said somebody had a nice
pair of lungs right so it's that kind of
stuff and again parents you know sadly
you know live with this every day
transition issues get to be a real
problem we mandate transition planning
in schools we don't always do such a
great job i would say unfortunately and
again the outcome studies interestingly
starting with connor suggests that for
reasons we don't totally understand some
people in adolescents take off other
people go the other way some of the
examples there's one man who I know
who's wrote his autobiography some years
ago was published in the Journal of
autism he was actually shown at Grand
Rounds Sally province in the 1950s
example of Connor's autism didn't talk
until he was four and a half he was
actually the nursery school here when he
started to talk he started talking in
full sentences about something that
happened the previous year and in
adolescence he had been kind of marginal
in adolescence he wanted to fit in he
ended up going to a trade school and he
does welding on submarines and it's a
perfect job for him it's very repetitive
he's very meticulous he does the same
thing over and over and over again
fantastic so medical issues we do know
that seizures are more frequent in
autism and they sometimes have their
onset metal essence I want to show you a
slide a second on that accidents
injuries and safety issues also become
problematic I can sadly tell you chapter
verse about many people things like the
child jumps out of the car on turnpike a
child who jumps in front of the freight
train is pulling into the station
drowning accidents are the leading cause
of death in autism and that's true for
all ages the symptoms of autism do
suppose challenges for the health care
system these are folks who are given a
limited which was their activity we have
poor prayer problems they tend to be
obese the medications we use often
unfortunate can be associated with
obesity all these are signs of trouble
and seizures in autism the light green
bars here show onset of seizures
recurrent seizures epilepsy
not just a febrile seizure recurrent
seizures in the green bar is a Cooper
5,000 British children is from the
British public health service and this
is age and years obviously once you
develop seizures for the first time you
can't develop again for the first time
so you drop out less than three 3 to 6 7
and 10 and so on that's the normative
sample by the time you're 15 to 18 less
than 1,000 kids developed seizures for
the first time in the typical population
the normative population this is a
sample from New Haven of four hundred
and some children this was a medical
student thesis and this is another large
sample from Boston and these are studies
that were not done about 10-15 years ago
thats remain actually the largest
studies ever done on this topic she
could see a peak of onset early in life
but another one in adolescence there's a
lady I take care of at the local group
home who in her 50s had her first
seizure and I got a call from the
Dartmouth ER and we had a discussion
about seizures and autism and I talked
to the ER doctor about this and he said
well you and we agree we wouldn't have
necessarily treat it we would see what
would happen she's not driving heavy
machinery etc and then he said to me
something like this back to the
challenges of the health care system
well as soon as she starts talking again
we'll let it go and I said well you know
I run the lady for 20 years and she's
never said a word to me so and again the
medical system doesn't always kind of
quite know what they're dealing with
unfortunately the seizures by the way of
all kinds most commonly major motor
insurance coverage is a problem often
choices are limited a health care reform
the new mandates we still don't know how
that's all going to play out you know
one of the worries sometimes when you
mandate universal coverage it means
minimal coverage for everybody but it's
universal so we'll have to you know it's
it's a tricky business well probably
have a chance to talk about this later
on in several context during the year
the transition from pediatrician to
adult based care can be a big challenge
family doctors can sometimes be more
engaged around these issues but it can
be a problem I've had interest call me
to say a 20 y/o wouldn't let them look
in their ear and so it's more like a
pediatric
that an adult problem psychiatric care
issues that again the tensions around
adult and child psychiatry people
sometimes think of her child
psychiatrist we only see children I'm
always explaining that people know it's
different than Pediatrics internal
medicine all child psychiatrist are by
definition adult psychiatrists as well
and clearly we need new models of care
we need a better system and we could
come up with I think very interesting
models thinking for example using nurse
practitioners people who have special
training that could be really minimal
minimal training that could really be
very instrumental in helping large
groups of children I mentioned often
there's an upsurge in behavioral
difficulties shortly before puberty it's
always hard to know what to make of this
people speculate about raging hormones
but they speculate about that in the
general population as well but it's a
very common experience of parents not
always and often fortunately it tends to
quote-unquote burn out after we hero to
the problem that when we get into of
this is a very complicated problem it
comes up in actually a couple of
respects the first is a problem of
so-called comorbidity having more than
one thing this is a dilemma in the
international classification of diseases
the tendency in general is to favor a
single diagnosis it's two favorite
parsimony you give autism that's it in
dsm it's a little more than thousand
flowers blooming approach in mont ism
the child we saw today had diagnosis of
autism and was a receptive expressive
language disorder okay that makes a lot
of sense and you could throw in others
and you can throw in a TD a child did
have potential issues and the child I'm
sure was anxious and then the problem is
which is I mean it's okay as long as
it's a convention you understand it the
difficulty is when people start taking
it seriously and follow-up each
diagnosis with a medication the record
number of medications I've seen a child
with autism on is 14 how in the world
you could disentangle what 14
medications are doing I do not know
paradoxically the other problem here is
what's called is the reverse of this
coin diagnostic overshadowing this came
to our awareness in the intellectual
disabilities world some years ago people
for years and years and years
to presume that having intellectual
disability or mental retardation can I
meant that was it all she wrote that's
the only problem well when you think
about it having a disability is only
going to make it more like you have
other troubles right still going to
protect you it's not like getting a flu
shot and in fact when people then took
things like the disc cancer the standard
diagnostic interviews and gave them to
people with mild levels of cognitive
impairment IQ 55 to 70 roughly their
rates of psychiatric difficulties or
four to five fold increased over the
general population which makes good
sense and it's not just every kind of
difficulty it's certain kinds of
difficulties depression anxiety mood
problems attentional issues so it's an
interesting you know paradox that sort
of what's the best approach to this and
there's no single simple answer another
problem of course is many of our
patients have very limited adore
idiosyncratic language they have
communication problems and a real
problem actually throughout age but into
adults and adolescents is the lack of
integration of treatment providers the
speech pathologist could be working
quite independently the psychologist
doing the social skills and eventually
be working quite independently of the
psychiatrist who's giving medications
for the attentional problems that's such
another challenge for the system that
unfortunately sometimes with good school
districts that can be largely dealt with
but as kids get out of school districts
having the parents or the child then the
young adult take responsibility that can
be an issue we do now have some limited
number of medications that are
officially FDA approved these treat
these so-called resistance to change
that's or third category of behaviors
the agitation the difficulties with the
stereotype mannerisms so far we don't
have medicines for the core social
difficulty of autism there's some hope
of this regard but not quite there yet
but we're working that direction there
is some suggestion of differences both
in terms of response to medications
before and after puberty the SSRI
medications which are very commonly used
in this population as far as one can
tell looking at the meta-analyses before
puberty don't really work quite so well
in children there was a wonderful study
that I don't larry's in the audience or
not
Larry Scott Hall was one of the authors
of with the rough group that made that
point sometimes the side effects can be
very problematic I mentioned the obesity
with risperidone which otherwise can be
very effective it can be a major
challenge and the research of course is
somewhat limited one of the difficulties
with the research is this is one of the
funny tensions around our tendency to
have evidence-based treatments you can
have such pure research groups that
they're not representative of the real
world so if you have a child with autism
you want to look at but I can't have XY
and Z and it can't be on medications it
can't have seizures the next thing you
know you're studying a very small group
of children risperidone I've mentioned
this was the study that was done
actually in part here I was the first p
I and then Larry took over for this
network that was based here of several
other sites around the country it was
collaborative a multi-site study it was
double-blind placebo-controlled we found
differences in two weeks after
medication of the active agent the
issues had to do with weight gain but
it's illustrative of the kinds of things
we could do if we got our act together
and did this in a more efficient way one
of the interesting things amples of this
was a federally funded study it was
basically imposed by the feds it didn't
quite go through the usual peer review
process this was actually funded after a
whole networker got done and the Fed
said okay we want you to work on this
one study together and that was kind of
how the system work and that's good but
that's the kind of thing you need to do
if we're going to increase work in this
area the kinds of areas we work on in
terms of intervention everything
adaptive skills communication social
sexuality mental health issues legal
issues vocational living arrangement and
I'll say a word about college adaptive
is real life skills this is the vineland
what we want to know is not where the
person can do math equations in their
head can they walk into McDonald's get a
cheeseburger and change and walk out
again and we have sadly examples of kids
where they are always doing math
equations in their head who cannot
possibly deal with McDonald's and so
this again is an important part of her
life is lived again one of the
tendencies in autism is a kind of a
gestalt learning style people learn
things in a whole chunk then they don't
like change they have very rigid
that turns it to be a real problem and
you want to generalize skills and it
becomes really important also becomes
exemplified around things like driving
driving is a big issue if you don't
drive in this country or in deep trouble
except if you live in very urban areas
fortunately there are a few approaches
to this it's a whole other interesting
topic there's a local man here in
Connecticut also than outlet in Florida
who is a special needs driving
instructor and if he takes you on he
will stick with you till you get a
license no matter how long it takes it
doesn't take everybody on he's a special
educator who also has training in the
area of autism is a wonderful guy to
work with this turns out to be a very
interesting thing the man that I
mentioned with our first eye tracking
studies with Virginia Woolf the movie a
he's a man who drives me does not drive
on the Turnpike he can't cope with it
and that's fine but you can drive
otherwise again that's that's wonderful
communication skills there's a
perception that most of the absolute
progress happens or the first five years
of life but even nonverbal adults can be
helped to be more communicative we were
showing a family today I prompts which
is something that's nonverbal just live
on your iPad or your iPhone it's
something to really help people become
more communicative and organized even if
they don't have language that's a
high-tech solution there's also low-tech
solutions pictures picture exchange
schedules of the group home that I
consult you with adults about probably
two-thirds of them are totally nonverbal
everybody has a bulletin board that
shows their schedule for the week as
they finish activities they turn
pictures over so they can see what's
coming next very adaptive social skills
there are all kinds of approaches to
teaching social skills these include
excusing peers especially with
preschoolers hybrid methods where we
combine kids for example in social
skills group and adult instruction most
of the research has been done with
younger children we've had a track
record here in town Nancy Moss for years
Kathy Koenig here is written a lovely
book and social skills trouble is much
of the research with older individuals
is quite limited it's very top-heavy in
the preschoolers summons school age and
then very little the time you get to be
adults and the social skills gap as we
talked about is tremendous and important
social skills are the most important
thing in terms of the definition we know
that social change happens over time the
social deficits have a major impact on
learning if you think about the child
who fails to attend to adults having
that child go to the first grade sit in
a little stool or chair pay attention to
a teacher focus on what she's saying or
he's saying that's a tremendous social
burner and if you and the amazing thing
is that most kids can do it and so you
can imagine if you're a child with
autism where the world is equally
irrelevant the ceiling is more
interesting in the floor than the
teacher that's going to be a problem for
learning and so the social things are
really very important and also the
social things are very important in
terms of generalization so if you get a
social vulnerability you're going to
have challenges for learning and you're
going to have challenges for
generalization we've talked about some
of the advances and gaze research we
know more and more again most of this
work has been done with younger children
but now we're at the point of thinking
about new animal models there's very
interesting stuff going on here both in
Paul Ambrosius lab but also Flores and
now with Hannah that we're really
thinking in new ways about the bridging
the gap between what we know in terms of
the genes in the brain and the behavior
one of the problems I again I would
emphasize is we have not perhaps has
done such a great job of translating
what we do know from research into the
world of schools and families social
skills teaching is more of a focus we do
need better research on this we need
support for people at all levels
paradoxically adults can use a lot of
social skills intervention and support
they're the hardest group to find social
skills and intervention support for and
I think it's interesting to think about
most of the work done with adults is
adult work with adults it's not peer
groups and it's not because the appears
you know it's like they're left in the
dust the time they get to high school
and so it's adults and it's very
explicit and it's very concrete and it
can be very helpful what we were talking
this morning in the autism clinic about
this it doesn't have to be and shouldn't
be sort of play based psychotherapy in
the sense of waiting for the child who
laborator theme and a fantasy
it's much more concrete about what
you're doing don't say this is these are
the rules rule 101 you know you don't
talk to ladies about their breasts in
public let's write that down or let's
roleplay how we're going to do it but
really very kind it can be tremendously
helpful it's more of a life coaching
model but an intensive psychotherapy
model but the problem is you going to
know what you're trying to teach but it
can be tremendously effective and and
really the patients can be wonderfully
rewarding to work with we also think
there's probably a good potential from
metric metro flying in some funny way
some of our understanding about the
social skills deficits to things like I
tracking looking at new measures Fred
shik is working along with Brian and
Adam Naples on some ways to actually
take our eye tracking gizmos out into
homes and schools we're actually doing a
project for the British art museum to
see what people look at when they're
looking at pictures sexuality issues
this is complicated as you can imagine
it's complicated for everybody even
worse if you've got a disability people
have more sexual interest people have
often the intense social feelings of one
kind or another there's all kinds of
stuff in terms of basic awareness
privacy issues what you can and can't
talk about who you can talk about it
with what can and can't be done and
where it can be done it may be okay to
masturbate in your bedroom but not in
the living room stuff like that which
sounds kind of simple in fact is very
complicated and sensitive one of the
further complexities for the adolescents
and young adults especially if the
adolescence is these are mostly boys who
are being taught by women which is
complicated so this is a very
interesting area there are some good
resources available actually for the
whole gamut ranging from very low
functioning too much more able people
and they're published curricula
guidelines there's videos there's all
kinds of stuff but again for parents to
know that this is out there and to be
able to tap into it we do need better
models for mental health service again
with this life coaching model and the
long haul we can be more proactive you
can do homework into roleplay it can be
very involved the insurance
reimbursement is a remains a problem
even with the passage of Obamacare and
parity we have troubles getting services
there are so many providers and often
the level of services not nearly what we
would like
legal issues come up in very interesting
ways for the more able students are kids
with Asperger's who talk a lot but have
a social disability paradoxically often
it's because they're rule-governed that
they get in trouble with the law the
classic example a few years ago was a
young no young well young adult late
adolescent who had saw a girl and the
grocery store and he knew this girl from
school and he wanted to say hello now we
had talked about how you say hello to a
girl right but he never done this in a
grocery store so that was already a
challenge right and he's got three
pickup lines right well none of these
can't figure it out because it's a
grocery store it's not as usual place so
here and he's muttering under his breath
he's rehearsing which he does and which
actually is adaptive for him he's
rehearsing what he's going to say so
this girl who vaguely knows that he's
aware of his existence she sees this guy
coming up behind her and he's getting
closer he's muttering and she's getting
nervous right and she'd get more nervous
and I'm very sympathetic in the father
of two young women and so she was to go
someplace where it's safe so she rushes
to the Express line which is the closest
line where there's an adult it says 10
items or less but she's got more than 10
items or cart and he's really worried
about she's gonna get into trouble so
what happens he starts to take stuff out
of her part so it's things paradoxically
like that or the kids the light changes
it says don't walk and the kids stops
the traffic is beeping I mean I've
literally seen patients hauled into the
ER because they thought they were
suicidal because they stopped when the
lights its but what so it's an
interesting very interesting and you can
never anticipate the that's the amazing
thing when you work with somebody I'm
always stunned by the things that people
don't know that the rest of us just
assume meltdown and aggression and
communication problems are real issues
for the less cognitively able especially
in public settings you will see people
who literally the police are called the
police may halt somebody off in
handcuffs without necessarily knowing i
was i think it was in illinois a few
years ago they told me that the EMTs
actually we're using ketamine to sedate
people
when they had meltdowns in public they
said very safe and I came back here and
talked to the chairperson of anesthesia
what do you think about that Roberta oh
jeez I wouldn't do it but it's
interesting one of the things that we
need to do a better job of is also
training people like firemen police
other folks to be more aware of what
autism looks like when somebody's having
a meltdown in public and again that
leads us to thinking about we have
models for doing this we have our own
police project here there are some
attempts around the country now to
provide specialty training for people
like policemen firefighters EMTs of what
to do and what not to do and again if
anybody's interested can give you some
examples of problem situations when it's
always surprised finally in terms of
legal issues transitions are mandated
under the law to be part of the planning
process is supposed to be doing this I
think starting around 15 the problem is
you'll see all kinds of sore ways that
this is approached not uncommon for
people to sort of give lip service and
then not do much at all or a symbol will
put them here for he'll volunteer at you
know Walmart or he'll be a greeter or
he'll but not meaningful things and it
really improves us to think more
proactively about what are good fits
there are some things that aren't going
to be good fits selling used cars or
vacuum cleaners or life insurance not a
good idea for a personally autism
spectrum computers on the other hand
very rigid rule governed repetitive
visual that's got something going for it
so it's thinking about that kind of
thing that could be helpful the health
insurance issues are of worry happily
with the new mandates for providing this
coverage for children to their
20-something years of age now that's a
plus but it's not uncommon for us as
children age into adulthood they lose
their parents health insurance coverage
maybe they're eligible for Medicaid
maybe not but that's a real problem and
lots of issues in terms of variability
from states in terms of who's
responsible guardianship estate planning
assumptions about siblings I tell
parents parents sometimes will assume
the younger sibling is just going to
take over the child's care that may or
may not be what the younger sibling is
thinking and you can only find out by
talking to them about so things like
that
also something just giving money not
always so smart either there was a
classic case of famous playwright in
this state a few years ago who died and
left a significant sum of money to his
child who had Down syndrome and was in
one of the state schools and of course
what happened the state took the money
there's a big bill so you have to be
careful in terms of your estate planning
there are ways to think about special
trust in their kinds of accommodations
but you have to have a good lawyer to
help you more and more people are
entering the workforce we've moved from
what used to be the kind of sheltered
employment model which was really make
work things that now we have supported
employment more and more for people and
many people who are truly independent
these are people who can be wonderful
workers I've given the example of the
man who did the copying business for
megs very consistent he's here rain or
shine it could be a blizzard out he came
from he walked from across town to get
here on a day when there's this horrible
blizzard as did our then speech
pathologist from Massachusetts who drove
down all the way in the horrible
blizzard I had a fellow who lived across
the street the apartments that couldn't
come so there are some pluses on the
other hand there are some issues to I'm
doing you some examples we can talk
about more of us have some time for
questions living arrangements group
homes support live an independent living
there's all kinds of pros and cons it's
an interesting thing there are more and
more transitional programs available
especially for the more able people a
growing population around the country
which gets us into thinking about
colleges and vocational schools college
is a different business than public
school education under public law 94-142
you're entitled to a free and
appropriate education up through high
school college is not a right under the
law college is a privilege now there is
a different law the Americans with
Disabilities Act that applies in
colleges that mandates services for
people with disabilities it's a
different business you can get kicked
out of college very easily and our kids
do and it's often around sexual stuff
which is unintended people will come up
make a very explicit request me if you
say no no cannot ask as many rules about
how you go to bed with a girl and here's
but you know there's 5,000 rules right
the person wants to work so go to home
plate directly and we'll ask a very
explicit make a very explicit sexual
request and can't understand because
he's very polite what the problem is a
debt academic skills could loom very
large there are a number now of
transitional programs we have one here
that we've been working with the autism
class that Jamie and I do during the
year for yale college students as
students work both at Ben Haven which is
a school for generally lower functioning
people and there's a program at chapel
haven for the more cognitively able who
are learning about being independent and
being able to go to college and again
it's a great and there's maybe 15 of
these programs around the country it's
fantastic we clearly need more emphasis
on research based treatments we need to
translate results from research into
practical applications I mentioned the
internet one of the problems for parents
is getting quality information we have
tried to do more and more in terms of
just that and again for parents we want
to provide quality and understandable
information on the tube on the YouTube
site on the internet if you go to
youtube type in Yale and autism up will
pop a series of 15 lectures this was
funded for us by some of the associates
it's the lectures from our autism class
it's things like genetics communication
infants with autism and it's free and
available in 50 languages I had somebody
last year and Cicely come up to me from
i think it was uzbekistan to say she'd
see my lecture on autism that's
fantastic and again it's out there it's
free and we hope it's quality but for
God's sake whatever else true is it CL
college there's a lot of misinformation
unfortunately the number of treatments
that come out for autism it's also like
the flowers in spring it's just amazing
often with minimal empirical basis and
sometimes posing risks to the child and
family helping parents become aware of
complementary and alternative
medications medical interventions is
important again it's a by definition if
it's complementing alternative there's
not an evidence base well there's not a
substantive evidence
days so that's a dilemma and I think in
general my experiences the pediatricians
underestimate the percent of parents who
are using complementary alternative
treatments because the parents could
divide but they don't want to talk about
it it's a psychiatrist ice I want to
talk about anything and so I think we
typically hear about ninety percent of
the younger parents of younger children
are using some kind of complementary
alternative treatment helping parents me
informed consumers and advocates is
really important I want to end by just
talking about some of the advances here
we have started some new services
clinical programs for adolescents young
adults we're trying to get up up and
running in terms of college planning
service we're expanding things in
Madison we have some new research
initiatives I mentioned the new
fellowship program we have for
adolescents and adults and we're trying
to do more in terms of outreach so in
summary there been many advances it's a
very exciting time there are issues in
terms of we need to translate our
research into effective practice and
developing models of care for
adolescents and young adults that could
be equally as effective as they are for
younger children let me stop there we
have a few minutes for questions